[Music]
y'all excited big Wisconsin primary on
actually I tricked three people into
being happy about that
three people like yeah the primary
number 88 in that state I don't care
about No
yes a little bit of a controversy going
on with Wisconsin primary Wisconsin
Democrats are accusing Mitt Romney of
handing out free sub sandwiches in
exchange for votes
yeah which explains why today Newt
Gingrich voted for Mitt Romney seven
times he kept going back big mega
millions controversy you've all heard
about this in Maryland a McDonald's
employee who won the Mega Millions is
fighting with co-workers who claim the
ticket was bought in an office pool yeah
you know the McDonald's it's the one
with the sign out front that says home
of the golden arches and that [ __ ]
Maureen
this is interesting the Miss Universe
pageant reversed its decision and will
now let a transgendered contestant
participate yeah the contestant was so
excited to hear this she could barely
hide her erection
[Applause]
now you know you're not at the voice
that's confirmation Goldman Sachs sold
their shares in the New York paper
Village Voice because it's back page has
ads for prostitution
so Goldman Sachs sold yeah Goldman Sachs
said the only people that should pay to
get screwed are their clients
hey the Tony Awards announced that Neil
Patrick Harris will host for a third
time so once again they've snubbed Mike
Ditka he Pike's them oh I love that joke
any chance to mentioned uh coach you
know that's the the man on the Quaker
Oats logo has gotten a complete makeover
including leaner face broader shoulders
and better hair yeah he also has a new
life partner Uncle Ben
[Applause]
yeah noose I don't know what that needs
a new study claims that four out of ten
Americans are now obese yeah the the
study was conducted by anyone working at
a water park
hey check this out scientists scientists
now believe that humans discovered fire
1 million years ago the evidence was
found on Larry King's first birthday
cake
[Applause]
there's no current that's why I'm not
drifting